bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time it's Friday
Rebecca Black wrists are playing that is
the theme music on Fridays what Wall
Streets trying to get rich the rest of
us is trying to get our lunch money
right I'm here with the beautiful and
intelligent plain Amer Nova she's got a
turtleneck on kind of looks like an
angel kind of looks like she might go
out and cut down some trees will Steve
Jobs wore a black one you got a white
one on cuz I'm an angel it's cuz you're
colorblind probably but don't forget now
lunch money I just got assaulted right
there on live television unless morning
sponsored by black far they've got three
products you can give them crypto
they'll give you US dollar loan you can
buy or sell crypto on their crypto
exchange and my favorite product as an
investor and the user is to earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account you put your
money in it's it's there there's risk do
your own research but they pay eight
point six percent APY which is pretty
damn cool what is not cool is the social
unrest is the social unrest on cool or
the social unrest pick what do you think
about it first let's start so if
everyone that hasn't been paying
attention
in the United States there's social
unrest occurring across multiple cities
some of it is violent some of it is not
what's your take first I think people
are fed up with police treatment of
certain communities and basically it's
boiled over and now you're gonna see
social unrest across America because
these people are sick and tired of it
this is exactly what I said was gonna
happen there are 40 million people who
have lost their jobs they are livid
they've been sitting at home it has been
like a tinderbox just waiting to get lit
on fire this was the most obvious thing
in the world to see coming but it's not
just because people have lost their jobs
yes it is
there are people who are livid they are
upset they are mad at their government
they don't care about the virus all they
know is on a day-to-day basis I had
income now I had a job now I don't know
what they are doing is the death of
George Floyd was an accelerant it's the
same thing like the virus all the
economic issues though they were going
to play out regardless when the
coronavirus hit it was the accelerant
it's the pin that popped the bubble and
then we got all the economic issues the
same thing is happening here the George
Floyd death is horrible people should be
really really mad
but unfortunately this happens there's
multiple things there's a death in
Louisville that they're protesting etc
these are serving as the catalyst for
that unrest and what you're seeing is a
perfect storm of social unrest because
you have people who already mad at their
government they were already mad at the
situation the socio-economic situation
that's played out over the last ten
weeks is so painful for these people and
then all they needed was a spark and
this death on video is that spark and by
the way I hear them like I actually
agree that the way that the government
is treated the people it all comes down
to one thing they forget the government
and the police serve our benefit they
are here to protect and serve they work
for the people
the mayor's the governor's the president
every single thing from the national
government the federal government all
the way on down they work for you I and
everyone watching the reason why people
are mad is because they have voiced
their concerns in every other way
possible and now they're bringing it to
the streets
yesterday we plane and I were talking to
earlier this morning I said to her I
watched an entire police department get
chased out of a police station they
literally all got in their cars and they
ran because of protesters they ran away
and the protesters went into the third
precinct in Minneapolis Minnesota and
they burnt it they literally set it on
fire if you watched those videos
it looks just like Benghazi where
terrorist is what they were called when
it's somebody that we don't like when
it's not our own citizens
it's no different people are upset
they're mad and the way to fix this is
through strong leadership that's real
which brings cohesiveness which says
together we are going to solve this
problem we are going to create the
change needed but what instead we're
seeing is we're seeing this divisive
miss morning there was a reporter that
was arrested on live television a CNN
reporter was arrested on live television
it is just you you can't start to eat
away at the fabric of society because
you lose the democracy you lose all of
the freedoms that the American ok let me
let me ask this how much of this is so
of course people are blaming the police
it's a horrible situation when the
police when the reporter got arrested I
watched an interview with him after he
was released and he said yeah I was walk
like ass he got ki handcuffed and walk
watch with the cop the state trooper he
asked them like hey man we're just
reporting like do you have any
guidelines on where we should stand and
report next time so we're not in your
way and the cop was like I don't know
man I'm just I'm just doing this because
I got orders look if you flip around so
part of being able to analyze these
situations is you have to be
intellectually honest enough right with
yourself and with the situation if you
look at this from the protesters
standpoint I hear you and honestly these
people are lashing out because they they
are the unheard voice right and they are
now going to make their voices heard
this is not just one incident this is a
litany of incident after incident after
incident that has now caused the
situation with that said if you flip
around and you put yourself in the
position of the police the police deal
with incredibly complex and hard
situations every single bit and 99% of
those situations go how they're supposed
to go the police are able to provide
justice they're able to provide order
they're able to protect insert
there are some bad apples we all know
that but I was asking a friend of mine
who's a cop when you arrest somebody how
many people say I can't breathe I can't
whatever and the thing is that everyone
pulls out their phone
everyone does all this stuff and so the
cops are in an impossible situation in
that unfortunately they don't recognize
what's right or not and so what I wish
that they would do is rather than just
pretend like it's never a serious
situation they treated people with
humanity and dignity and said we're not
going to kneel on their necks that would
probably be a good place to start we're
not going to ignore when people say they
can't breathe right I get that they are
desensitized to it because it happens
every day but that doesn't mean that
because you're desensitized you don't
take it seriously and so actually what I
think is is a huge issue here is we've
done a poor job as a country in training
or police departments if you look at how
they handle situations it's always with
the strongness use of force it's always
guns drawn right and what we can do is
instead if you start retraining officers
on how to handle these situations I
think you can actually defuse a lot of
the bad stuff do you remember that
situation on the New York City Subway
where these two guys I think it was
Sweden or three guys from Sweden and
they like managed to get this guy who
had a knife or a gun this am not I'm not
sure but they were able to get him like
down and like they were talking to him
and it wasn't violent and they were like
they're just trained in a different way
well I think part of it is you don't
want to put the officers life at risk
right by the way the reason why we have
police officers is because most people
don't want to do that job right they're
sworn to protect and serve us and
there's a saying I forget the guy who
says it but it's basically most people
sleep at night because there's rough men
ready to do violence on their behalf
right and so when you think of it that
way it's yes that there is a police
force but to your point I think it's the
training can help
and then also some compassion some
empathy right understanding look there's
40 million people have lost their jobs
they are going to have a higher rate of
irritability
they're going to be more upset all this
kind of stuff and when there's a
catalyst like the George Floyd situation
it's bad by itself you then layer in all
all of this kind of pent-up anger I
actually think this would have happened
without the virus do you think so yes do
you do you think that it would be in
every city or just Minneapolis I think
it would be across the country because
the video exists because the video
exists and it's so it's one of those
videos where it's like very hard to say
it's not black-and-white you you see it
you see what happens and that's it I
think we agree that people would have
been mad and outraged I don't know if
people would have gone out in the
streets and worked on the police station
without all of the other anger I think
there's just a lot of anger across the
board but I think that this is just I
mean after a while people lose their
patience say enough is enough and they
just and that's it and I think that this
is in a series of events that we've seen
on video I think this one kind of like
the cup the cup ran over yeah I mean
look people forget
literally just a couple of weeks ago
when the jogger there's a guy who was
jogging and there's all kinds of facts
that are still coming out about it but
there's a man who was shot on the road
by two private citizens and wants to be
a cop is to get in this situation of
just it's not good so our message to
everyone please please please please any
kind please be kind to people right now
obviously people are on edge we spent 10
minutes and 15 seconds talking about it
okay we're done let's go
Softbank what's up Softbank first of all
there's two things going on it's leading
500 million dollar investment in Chinese
ride hailing from Dee Dee's self-driving
unit they got cash man they gonna deploy
that cash they record losses of 18
billion and at the same time they're
doubling the softbank's vision fund CEOs
paid 215 million
yeah I mean look it's really hard to
look at CEO pay type stuff you can make
the argument that he's leading through a
crisis well and and they were gonna
leave like you don't know what's going
on behind closed doors right and so I'm
always on the CEO pay stuff like the
data always looks horrible
you just don't have the context of the
actual situation so it's hard to to
judge good or bad but I but it doesn't
look good when you double the CEOs pay
as you're losing 18 billion dollars for
sure in in terms of DD I think they're
just kind of trying to double down on
what's already working because they know
a lot of their other startups are gonna
go to zero I mean look
salt driving cars are coming on
autonomous cars right and this idea of a
robo taxi which is basically think of it
today you press a button and a car comes
to pick you up but it's got a driver in
it eventually gonna press a button and
the cars gonna come pick you up
but we know driver it'll kind of be like
the Jetsons if you guys ever seen that
and so Dee Dee's going after this uber
is going after this Tesla is going after
this and they're making an investment
five hundred million dollars is not that
much money of their fund but still it's
having a million dollars so I think
they're doubling down I think they're
already an investor in GD but now
they're just in the autonomous driving
yeah I mean look they're in a bad
situation and so like all of a sudden
you become less risk-averse right you
start to take bigger swings cuz you
gotta get out of here your whole
probably watching that happen so we'll
see
industrious okay so industrious is a
rival co-working company too
we work and funny enough funnily enough
in 2018 I wrote an article about
industrious raising more money but they
could raise like tens of millions of
dollars whereas we work had raised like
a billion and I said at the time which
now looks not so good I was like well
you just you can't even compare
industrious to we work because we work
is just go it just has more capital and
it's the 800-pound gorilla how the hell
is industrious gonna compete against we
work and today we see that doesn't just
because you have all the money doesn't
mean you can compete what's the story
that toward us in the hair right and the
whole idea is as we talked about before
too much capital can kill a company and
we work definitely fell victim to that
industrious it remains to be seen
whether they'll be successful will
actually get the IPO out the door in the
spring of next year but they're taking
steps to do it and part of it I think
that's pretty interesting is just
they've stayed steady they've kind of
done what they're supposed to do and if
you
think of we saw this with uber and lyft
lift was very kind of pragmatic compared
to Ober in terms of the cash burn and
how much money they raise and all that
and both companies are doing okay and so
I think same thing here are we is it a
good idea to be in a co-working space
right now like the for your company to
be in co-working spaces more and more
companies are saying you can work from
home well you can look at the two ways
one is let's say that your headquarters
was in industrious or we work and now
some CEOs or founders may say hey look
we don't need that anymore like everyone
work from home but also I know a lot of
companies that say hey Polina you're
able to work from home now but you live
in a different city we're gonna shut
down the New York office and then you
want an office because you don't you
know it's hard work from home there's
distractions whatever so they'll get you
a membership to a place like industrious
or we work see if so where to go so I
think it'll kind of net out it'll be
interesting to see but I don't think we
can make that call to the ultimate
tortoise and hare story if industrious
manages to do an IPO where as we work
did not alright us savings what's going
on there okay people are saving a lot of
money the u.s. savings rate hit record
33% as coronavirus caused
Americans to stockpile cash people are
nervous and they can't spend money
because they can't leave their home
historic 33 percent yeah I mean look
it's when you see the numbers it's
usually in kind of around 10 to 15
percent so it's almost double or more
than double where it historically has
been but people are nervous so what do
you want you want cash cash is king in
times of uncertainty so we've are
hoarding cash saving and then two is you
can't go out to restaurant you can't go
to bars you can't go to stores you can't
go wherever so of course they're
spending less money I've been like
ordering some things online guys there's
box after box doing nothing I asked her
what is it she's like oh this is like my
shoes this is a sports bra that's what
came like two days ago it's portable do
your thing no what are some underwear
after all right what's going on
meditation apps I might need to use some
meditation apps are you sure yeah
boxers or briefs leave a comment all
right go ahead let's go to meditation as
meditation apps are surging and down I
will not be happy with you I'm being
kind of my friends you see guys this a
person who is being kind um okay so
mental health app so headspace and calm
are seeing a surging downloads also with
seeing a surge is mental health issues
there was a survey done by the US
consensus and they say one in three
Americans are basically mentally uneasy
ziz how those are my words not theirs
but basically things like depression
anxiety all that kind of stuff and so
this is kind of a correlated thing where
if people are feeling that way doesn't
surprise me that meditation what have I
been meditating lately oh man listen as
we all know I can't do meditation
because I fall asleep
planta meditates my life is [ __ ]
coasted easy life they say once a happy
wife easy life no meditated wife easy
life have you been calmer yeah I'm
always 24/7 can we do this in three
minutes old cognac one of the oldest
bottles of cognac has sold at auction
for nearly 150 K guess how old is
popping bottles in the club it's
probably from 1850 1762 I was only off
by 100 years is that crazy yeah that is
pretty cool $150,000 yeah just like one
good night in Vegas whatever okay listen
popping bottles now here's the question
is if you buy a bottle of alcohol for
$150,000 that's more than what 200 years
old or no more than 150 years old or so
yeah do you drink it or do you hold it
wait let me tell you the fun you
drinking or do you hold it you can't
drink it look at it yes you can it's
alcohol I don't know I wouldn't drink it
so my my family in Bulgaria do you
remember when I went to my grandfather's
we there one re there for the bottles
what about it so rakia is the Bulgarian
alcohol and like you can like have it or
make it or whatever
what so anyway so he has all these
bottles of like I don't know 90 year old
rakia but he doesn't drink so it's
really fun so they just sit there 90
years old and what is he gonna do with
them maybe I should sawn 450k upon them
as gifts okay maybe I should selling
anybody want to buy a hundred ninety
year old bottle of rakia hit me up I got
it I'll give you a 50% discount only 75
K a bottle so take off ready how excited
are you hype tomorrow
3:22 p.m. get ready SpaceX we launch in
humans to space we're gonna be
live-streaming I guess starting around
what I watched yesterday
bring your pizza bring your Bud Lights
and bring your rocket [ __ ] tomorrow's
your cheat day let's go
but like water for the common man
Domino's just pizza for the common man
and rocket ships
she's obviously meditated so much that
she's falling asleep in the middle of
lunch money again we'll deal with this
later tomorrow around one o'clock we'll
be live-streaming it'll be awesome and
to finish out today lunch money time we
are giving away a hundred dollars to
people but one person to be kind to
their friends and to get this lunch
money this week umm tweet what 9 thing
you're gonna do with it take the URL
tweet it use hash tag lunch money and we
want to hear if we give you the hundred
dollars what's the kindest thing perfect
that you're gonna do with it thank you
tweet the URL hashtag lunch money 100
bucks to the winner i'll DM you send you
the money do whatever you want with it
but just tell us what the kindest thing
is you're gonna do with it
any last words for the people on a
Friday no are you sure yeah but we did
it in under 20 minutes yeah great you
look like an angel
that's it for lunch money today well
Wall Street is trying to get rich thrust
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
be kind to your friends understand that
the world is suffering right now and
we'll see you guys on Monday morning
bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got 3
products they can give you a US dollar
loan you can earn up to eight point six
percent interest on an interest-bearing
account or you can buy and sell crypto
currencies on their crypto exchange I
personally use the interest-bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest on a deposit in an
interest-bearing account go do your own
research there's risk associated but
eight point six percent it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block by subscribe to our channel like
the video annoy playing in the comment
and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends